une victoire de plus pour le val de
loire le site de la confluence où se
rejoignent la loire et la vienne vient
d'être classée en zone de protection
renforcée par le conseil d'état un joli
coup de pouce pour les communes
concernées mais attention aux nouvelles
contraintes pour l'habitat aurait dû
renaud
cante saint-martin dominé par sa
collégiale le site est exceptionnel
la confluence presque 3000 hectares qui
bénéficie aujourd'hui d'une protection
renforcée
la mission val de loire fait vivre cette
reconnaissance depuis plus de 20 ans
elle accompagne les collectivités dans
leur prise de décision concernant le
patrimoine désormais chaque projet ayant
un impact sur le paysage dans cette zone
sera instruit au sommet de l'état ce qui
change pour ce territoire c'est
essentiellement que tout ce qui va être
entrepris et qui aurait demandé une
autorisation particulière déclaration
préalable permis de construire autre va
être instruit à des niveaux qui sont des
niveaux nationaux des niveaux
ministériels parce que justement ce site
est classé et donc c'est un niveau de
protection pour en garantir finalement
l'intégrité effectivement l'état n'a pas
estimé en 2000 au moment de
l'inscription
capable enfin
gérable finalement une un classement
total de la loire des 300 km de loire
huit communes sont concernées par le
décret du conseil d'état parmi elles
teasé et ses 288 isea un village sur les
coteaux viticoles de la vienne
le maire se réjouit de ce classement il
fera rayonner le patrimoine communal
comme l'église ou encore ce grand
domaine nommer la pierre couverte
côté urbanisme
l'élu a quelques craintes concernant les
installations dans son village et les
demandes de travaux de ses habitants je
demande à voir il faudra voir comment
les dossiers seront instruits par la
suite notamment dans la les demandes de
permis de construire
qu'ils vont remonter au plus haut de
l'état et qui vont peut-être freiner
certaines personnes à
améliorer leur habitat ou à créer
construire
de leur habitat le maire espère ne pas
être freinés dans un projet déjà bien
avancé pour ce bâtiment qu'il souhaite
transformer en une bibliothèque
agrémenté d'un petit débit de boisson
pour créer du lien dans son village